banlieue de liège janvier dernier nous
sommes chez lara binet 23 ans candidate
wallonne malheureuse de miss belgique
voilà ça c'était une photo de thaïlande
avec d'autres miss un concours de miss
qui va raviver la guerre entre wallons
et flamands en thaïlande on était sur un
bateau et une vanne sortir oui c'est une
bateau coule
on laisse lara se dit victime de
discrimination de la part des
organisateurs de miss belgique et a
porté plainte contre eux elle les accuse
d'avoir été partiale
en élisant justine de jonckheere une
candidate flamande
le jury était composé de huit personnes
et il était composé à concurrence de 6
personnes néerlandophones et deux
personnes francophones le déséquilibre
était était évident l'organisatrice du
concours est une dame d'origine
néerlandophone le concours se déroulait
dans la partie néerlandophone du pays
pour le père de lara ce déséquilibre en
faveur des néerlandophones est bien la
preuve que les flamands règlent leurs
comptes avec les wallons quand vous avez
une ex miss belgique qui fait partie du
jury qui fait partie d'un parti
extrémiste du nord du pays qui se permet
de dire devant les milliers de
spectateurs à la télévision en direct
soir de la finale moi je ne voterai que
pour une miss qu'ils parlent néerlandais
ce qui aurait pu passer pour une simple
querelle de miss a pris une dimension
politique
surtout depuis que le nationaliste
flamand bart de wever s'en est emparé
on le voit ici piétiné le drapeau aux
côtés de la miss belgique 2010 et fermin
de couper la belgique en deux avec ses
ciseaux car le grand gagnant des
dernières élections prône la partition
du pays et n'hésite pas à comparer les
francophones à des étrangers
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de minorités en
flandre et à des immigrants qui doivent
s'adapter
cette guerre linguistique remonte à 1830
date de l'indépendance du royaume de
belgique composée de néerlandophones et
de francophones mais à l'époque le
français est décrétée seule langue
officielle n'est alors un profond
malaise entre les deux communautés
soixante-trois mille flamands ont défilé
dans les rues de la capitale belge
on crie de bruxelles flamand slogan
auquel les fédéralistes wallon est
conduit par d'autres slogans la belgique
11 millions d'habitants 60% de flamands
40% nous allons et 1% de germanophones
au sud
la wallonie francophone au nord la
flandre néerlandophone au centre
bruxelles région et capitale bilingue
enclavée en flandre
c'est cette frontière linguistique tracé
en 1963 que contestent les voiles ont
encore aujourd'hui
il accuse les flamands d'avoir grignoté
le territoire belge au profit de leur
communauté
nous sommes sur cette frontière
linguistique à enghien une ville située
à cheval sur la wallonie et la flandre
et on se trouve ici à la frontière
linguistique nous quittons en rien nous
entrons dans le brabant flamand vous
avez le panneau d'ailleurs d'accueil de
bienvenue gérer une commune réglementée
par deux lois différentes
un casse tête administratif pour florine
pary mille maire de cette commune de 13
mille habitants vous voyez derrière moi
le service des incendies dans bien donc
il se trouve en région wallonne et puis
derrière moi nous nous trouvons en
région flamande et toutes les maisons
que vous voyez ici derrière elles
dépendront d'un service qui se trouve à
25 km d'ici autant dire qu'il vaut mieux
se trouver du bon côté de la frontière
autre casse-tête pour madame la maire le
cimetière d'enghien il est situé en
flandre alors que la commune se trouve
en wallonie problème les wallons et les
flamands ne s'enterre pas de la même
façon les corps flamands doivent reposer
au dessus du sol
même sous terre les deux communautés
trouve le moyen de se distinguer une
famille qui souhaiteraient enterrait son
défunt au cimetière d'enghien et qui
émettrait le souhait que ce cercueil
soit au dessus du niveau du sol donc
dans une sépulture au dessus du niveau
du sol en région wallonne c'est interdit
alors que la région flamande e
l'autorisent l'entretien des sépultures
la dispersion des cendres
l'enterrement des foetus autant de
désaccord que madame la maire aimerait
régler au plus vite au pays des
aberrations administratives bienvenue
dans la commune de tervueren qu'ici chez
marx homme vil la frontière linguistique
coupe même la maison de la partie avec
la terrasse ccre nm la partie sans trace
c'est sérieux roues une maison à cheval
entre deux communes tervueren et
kraainem et il faut dire que le père de
marc a acquis cette maison en 1949
bien avant le tracé définitif de la
frontière linguistique
donc ici je suis en flandre dans une
commune où on ne peut parler que
néerlandais là je suis dans une commune
où on peut parler et de l'anc
parfois un peu compliqué quand on va à
la commune pour les papiers pour les
contributions pour toutes sortes de
choses comme ça donc il faut parler
néerlandais
hélas parfois ça disons que c'est un
petit peu compliqué
en belgique être francophone du côté
flamand est de plus en plus difficile le
gouvernement régional imposent aux
habitants de ne parler que le
néerlandais
nous nous sommes rendus dans cette amp
eaux de la ville de halle en caméra
cachée nous nous sommes fait passer pour
des demandeurs d'emploi francophone
bonjour bonjour je suis donc un habitant
de namur mais je vais à venir
m'installer ici sur ce rallye est ce que
c'est possible vous pensé trouver du
travail vous parlais pas français dirigé
par l'on est obligé de parler français
et deux néerlandais
donc je dois je prendre des cours en et
vous mais vous pouvez pas voir les
français et c'est la loi c'est bien ici
à halle où partout ici pas de travail
pour ceux qui ne parlent pas le
néerlandais
en flandre il y a seulement 8% de
chômage en wallonie près de 20
symbole de cet apartheid linguistique la
ville de linkebeek 5000 habitants située
en flandre mais à la périphérie de
bruxelles alors particularité la commune
de linkebeek elle se trouve en terre
flamande malgré ses 86 % de francophones
l'unilinguisme et de rigueur alors que à
trois mètres de ma commune nous arrivons
comme vous pouvez le voir en région
bruxelloise qui est une région bilingue
et qui permet aux habitants tant
francophones que néerlandophones de
s'exprimer dans leur langue en toute
démocratie à linkebeek la démocratie a
une façon bien spéciale de s'appliquer
pendant la réunion du conseil municipal
il est interdit de parler le français
sinon la séance est annulé ces deux
conseillers municipaux sont les seuls
néerlandophones les 13 autres sont
francophones
et pour le maire adjoint parler le
néerlandais est un véritable défi des
efforts loin de faire l'unanimité chez
les néerlandophones qui pourtant parle
couramment le français
tout à fait
louis ide du temps dans notre notre dans
la région quoi
lorsque moi j'avais en angleterre même
si que 17 pour deux semaines je
m'arrange pour parler
ce qui est encore plus surprenant c'est
que si les deux conseillers municipaux
néerlandophones vieira quitté le conseil
nous sommes obligés malgré tout de
continuer en néerlandais et pour être
certain que tout se passe bien il y à un
inspecteur qui est déléguée par
l'autorité supérieure pour venir suivre
l'entièreté nos conseillers comme une
autre guerre des langues mais aussi
guerre économique suite du voyage le
long de la frontière linguistique
nous nous rendons à ypres côté flamand
jusque dans les années 60 la wallonie
était prospère grâce à la sidérurgie
aujourd'hui la flandre est plus riche un
écart de richesse qui exacerbe encore un
peu plus les tensions entre les deux
communautés
yann ouateux lui tint entrepreneurs
flamands il a fait fortune dans le
meuble australie mais bon c'est mélanger
un petit peu tous des chambres à coucher
j'achète beaucoup en france pour yann où
as tu eu une chose est sûre les wallons
ne travaille pas assez et profitent du
système et sont encore en jeu c'est un
autre natalité c'est notre mentalité
j'ai bloqué j'ai beaucoup de copains qui
soit valence à sont des gens très
amusant ça ça sert de parler de manger
le beauf et de s'amuser de boire la
cuisine ce sont des gens très amusant
mais les flamands sont plus courageux y
aurait-il d'un côté les courageux et de
l'autre les assister les flammes ont en
tout cas disent ne plus vouloir payer
pour les wallons pour cet économiste
il faudrait même 38 ans à la wallonie
pour rattraper l'économie flamande des
flammes au qui aujourd'hui doivent
reverser par solidarité 6 milliards
d'euros à la wallonie
chaque année la flandre plus riches
cotisent plus aux mécanismes de sécurité
sociale finance davantage les recettes
de la sécurité sociale
par contre à boloni et bruxelles qui a
plus de chômeurs notamment bénéficient
davantage de ses mécanismes et c'est un
économiste wallon qui le dit
la sécurité sociale et le chômage wallon
un fardeau fiscal dont les séparatistes
flamands voudraient bien se débarrasser
pour l'opposition ce serait la fin de la
belgique
un scénario d'une partition que la
télévision publique avait mise en scène
en 2006 dans un faux journal
bonsoir à tous leurs est grave excusez
nous pour cette interruption à événement
exceptionnel moment exceptionnel la
flandre va proclamer unilatéralement son
indépendance vous l'avez compris le
moment est important en clair la
belgique en tant que tel n'existerait
plus il y a cinq ans ce gag réalisé dans
les studios de la chaîne avait fait
trembler le pays depuis la réalité a
rattrapé la fiction
le gouvernement belge est paralysé je
sais absolument pas ce qui va se passer
est la pire des choses qu'un journaliste
ne sache pas ce qui va se passer bon c
c'est la vie mais à l'heure actuelle il
n'y a aucun homme politique qui est
autour de la table et qui négocient qui
est capable de dire aujourd'hui il y
aurait une issue dans une semaine dans
deux semaines dans trois mois ou
d'encadrement et jeu contre la véritable
angoisse aussi bien sûr de la population
mais des politiques responsables qui
négocient c'est celle là c'est de ne pas
savoir comment on va sortir baptisme la
crise
elle a démarré il y à déjà plus de neuf
mois au lendemain des législatives
aucun des sept partis politiques belges
n'avaient pu se mettre d'accord sur un
gouvernement de coalition
ni les nombreux médiateurs ni les appels
du roi à négocier non changer quelque
chose
et courage consiste à chercher fermement
le compromis qui rassemble et non à
exacerber les oppositions le 23 janvier
dernier les belges organise la marche de
la honte après 224 jours de vacance du
pouvoir en belgique le pays s'exaspère
ou allons et flamands main dans la main
réclame un gouvernement au milieu de la
foule d'inconnus une personnalité très
célèbre en belgique et en france
le dessinateur philippe geluck la
révolution est en marche
la révolution des moules frites
contrairement à celle du jasmin qui a
déjà abouti en tunisie nous ont donné
l'exemple
alors évidemment ici fait moins beau
mais
c'est en route record battu dans la
catégorie des pays sans gouvernement
les belges viennent de devancer les
irakiens cela fait ce soir 266 jours que
la belgique n'est plus gouverné